Ben Shapiro I saw you mentioned me on
the iced coffee Hour podcast I'd be
interested in debating Destiny I think
we should have a debate over who the
next president of the United States
should be and I bet Jubilee would host
the debate for us this is the 113th
episode of middle ground and we want you
to help us decide what the next 113
episodes will be join our Middle Ground
patreon community and make middle ground
with us
[Applause]
the gay community is over sexualized
can the agreeers please step forward
thank you the gay community because you
know it's based off of our sexual
attraction it has a very easy time going
into a space that's all about sex to me
being gay is a lot more than who I sleep
with you know it's it's an experience
from when I grew up the movement used to
be about love but then you go to a pride
parade now and you're seeing old men
with their
genitals out I think everybody has a
right to like Express their sexuality in
the ways that they do it so on those
grounds I'm not like offended by these
old people like doing what they're doing
but I do agree with that I think like
one of the biggest challenges when I was
coming out to my dad who's Muslim it was
like my sexuality being gay isn't just
about my sexual lust for other men it's
more about the spiritual connections the
in-depth things like me as a whole
complex person but I do think that our
experiences and our existence has kind
of been trivialized by the over
sexualizations I don't think it's
inherently an evil and the over
sexualization is apparent in the apps
that we can get I mean you can literally
have sex on demand or you could find it
in a location wherever you want certain
businesses are actually keeping doors
open because men are having sexual
relations in the bathrooms and that's
inappropriate I mean we want our privacy
too just like women and now we can't
even have our privacy because a small
sect of men ruin it for us yeah and that
was really frustrating too when I came
out the closet it was like I had this
innate pressure ago I have to download a
grinder I have to be super sexualized
and that's really bad on our youth
because although everyone has sex I get
that but why advisor that our community
is hyper focused on that I haven't
attended many Pride events because of
that reason I was able to go to Portugal
and there was this queer Retreat and it
was like the first time I felt like safe
and secure as a queer person because it
wasn't sexual and I could have these
relationships with queer men but there's
no expectation to be sexual yeah and we
see it at the bars I mean it's a Google
you go to a gay
clubs
I mean I avoid them at all costs at this
point dang what what no problem be
without you rogany but you know it's not
just me it's a team effort too it's
yours to that
which is why we want to thank millinote
for sponsoring this episode
Milano is a creative project management
tool that lets you collect notes images
videos tasks and more all in one place
whether you're planning a season of
middle ground or planning your next
creative project milanote has different
templates that you can choose from our
team even used it to have everything in
place for this season of Middle Ground
from casting to research and
brainstorming which was simple enough
because milanote allows you to share
your work with others and collaborate
with them in real time oh yeah talk
about teamwork making the DreamWork
is available for free with no time limit
sign up using the link in the
description and start your next creative
project thanks so much to Milano for
sponsoring this portion of the episode
now let's get back to the video
foreign
I think it's easy to generalize our
communities over sexualize because we're
in it so we're focused on it but if you
look at the straight Community I think
they're doing a lot of what we're doing
especially now with more sexual
Liberation becoming a thing for them in
their community
I also think that we have to remember
like we've only been legal as in like
decriminalized in our sex for 20 years
this year that's crazy every year up
until 20 years ago like there's going to
be an explosion of people wanting to
embrace their sexual Liberation and then
you look at things like the AIDS
epidemic in the 80s like that took away
so many people and it made us afraid to
have sex so this in my opinion is a way
for us to overcome stuff and we
definitely need to find a balance the
basis for making us illegal has always
been based on sex and so being openly
sexual in any way at all whatsoever is
inherently a protest inherently
subversive I mean there are sexual
things that happen to public that I'm
sometimes uncomfortable with but that
doesn't mean that all the things we see
and all the things our friends see
represent the majority of experiences a
huge portion of lgbtq people exist in
zero public lgbtq spaces I think you
draw the line of you do this in the
comfort of your home and you can show
affection in public I don't know if we
need to be like indecent in public I
don't know if that would be considered
redefining decent I've like when I I'm
in a 20-year relationship a 20-year
monogamous relationship with my husband
and I say husband even though we're not
married but we're not groping each other
in public we can pack we we joke around
when we walk into a room they know we're
together because we give yes absolutely
we hope we show Extra affection at home
in the privacy of our home or in the
privacy of friends homes because we feel
comfortable in that and you know that
what that though is your specific
preference for public affection there
are a million problems out there for
with heterosexual people and a fun funny
thing seen in that movie is straight
people having sex in some public space
correct this is a I still don't think
that's appropriate people I don't
necessarily do either I'm just saying
we're talking about personal preferences
I know but I think a lot of times in
this and I don't disagree with what you
guys said but a lot of times what I'll
hear is like well the straight people do
this and I always grew up saying I clean
my house before I tell somebody else to
clean theirs I'm not straight therefore
if straight people are doing something
wrong and gay people are doing something
wrong I'm going to address the gay
people that are doing something wrong
like the people who have been setting
the stage for all us to like follow suit
with you know like we live in a
heteronormative culture like everything
that we see is based off of the way that
they exist the whole idea of over
sexualization and things like that I
think the danger in it is that for so
long it's been weaponized against us so
we're always kind of like under this
magnifying glass of like oh well can I
hold hands can I kiss this person and
then you know I don't think we
necessarily have to like mimic quote
unquote bad behavior simply because that
was what was served to us
pride is still necessary
yeah I think Pride's necessary but we
need a PR revamp
yeah I think we need a Rebrand I take a
lot of issues with what I see at Pride
parades now uh just because you know as
we discussed previously I think that
it's a little bit over sexualized we're
celebrating essentially sex rather than
love and we have people running around
riding bikes with their balls out in
front of kids and for me why are you
seeing this yeah
um New York City and Seattle both of
those had naked people walking the
streets in San Francisco one of them was
on a bike I saw the video of him on a
bike I didn't I would never have my
balls out on a bike that sounds good no
me either it's dangerous me either but
it's the fact that it is allowed because
we have this Shield of its Pride don't
mess with gay people because of our
history which is is granted but people
are afraid to look at our culture and
say that's not acceptable because if
straight people were walking around
doing that it would be a totally
different discussion I don't think
that's the majority of the issue though
I mean the reality is that being visible
period is vital yeah
none of us will be alive to see the day
when heterosexual people and homosexual
people have equal agency in what's
allowed and what's not allowed in the
public space me personally I actually
think Pride is very necessary I love it
I wouldn't say Pride parades I feel like
um you guys are leaning towards like the
parades itself pride is like Liberation
you know you're proud of who you are and
yeah yeah accepting yourself and having
the people around you in your circle
really accept you it really tells the
future generation like not only is it
okay but look how far we've come at 2011
you know the don't ask don't tell policy
was abolished I'm in the military and
had that not been abolished I would not
be able to be you know a minority be
openly gay and still be able to serve my
country yeah and I want to just say
thank you for your service before I move
on and and that's a prime example of the
pride that I would love to attend is
someone who highlights service members
gay service members gay CEOs people who
are successful who are contributing to
society celebrate who you are love who
you are but the pride is no longer about
being overly promiscuous because we're
not allowed to we don't need to over
correct to the point that we start to
get backlash we we need to correct our
PR I still think we're looking at a
small group of the people that aren't
Prime as they speak the loudest but they
don't always you said you saw two people
naked like from those two separate
instances of groups of people who were
naked exactly right around the world
highlighted looking at specific things
with a level of Shame and then have to
look at like where are we shameful
within ourselves and why is that
something that we should be ashamed of
in general like why is nudity shameful
in general I agree with you about nudity
itself is not sexual I don't think so
because I have been to new places it's
not sexual but when you make it sexual
that's the problem it can be indecent
exposure at some of these things and
pride needs to not be complacent and
address it
this should be interesting
I'm alone on this one but the reason I'm
alone on this one is because I organize
one of the most successful Prides in my
community in 2016. I invited groups that
were outside the norm like the NRA and
the local GOP including the Democrats
because for me it was important that
this event reached the entire Community
more than just saying we are a sexual
being we wanted to educate the people I
was told I was never allowed to help
them again because how dare I invite a
hate group like the NRA when all I
wanted to do was arm LGBT people and
educate them on how to protect
themselves because as you guys said
there are those people who would hurt us
I live in a very very red Community okay
Mike Garcia is my representative
yeah
but I dress like this to Galas big
government Galas realtor Galas no one
has said anything to me and in fact all
I get is positive affirmation that hey
you're living your best life and I say
it's not really necessary because says I
can walk down my street in heels and
braids in California yeah you are so
privileged in that way in Republican
controlled California all of
Californians found that 35 of
Californians feel that homosexuality
should be discouraged I've done this in
Michigan I've done this in Michigan I've
done this in Tennessee I've done this in
Missouri I've done this yes in all those
States yes I have yes I have and I've
had absolutely no issues I've walked
into a Backwoods Bar in the middle of
Nashville where it was a double wide
that had been converted to a bar and it
was one of those records scratch your
husband look like my husband is six foot
four and he's and there's her imagine
that's not my protection I walk in that
Community dressed just like this in
these heels and not only do I not get
hey my husband gets more business I'm so
happy for you that this is true for you
I really am yeah but the reality is that
you represent a small minority of lgbtq
people and how they actually experience
life in America to your like sense of
Freedom which is so admirable I think
that those things are built on blocks of
people who probably did feel that Pride
was necessary so it's a beautiful thing
that we can have the freedom to you know
change your mind admire that yeah and I
think we all want everyone to feel the
way that you feel like you don't need it
but that's just not the case my name is
John and I am a patreon member who is
asked to read you this next prompt
the LGB should be separated from the
tqia Plus
saying they should be separated is not
saying that one is you know less
important yeah so I do want to start
with that but I do think that the LGB is
very specific rooted in science it's
very clear as a day we have lesbian gay
and bi
main difference between male and female
we all know what that is the reason why
I step forward with hesitation was
because I think that there are such
lived differences and experiences that
we experience although collectively I
think that we all know
the collective experience of being a
sexual deviant there just is a
difference in lived experience that I
think is is important to talk about and
acknowledge and that's my grounds for
agreeing with perhaps a separation mine
is very different to be clear the
science is very solid on uh identities
other than gender assigned at Birth
being valid science is very clear robust
there is no question that it's legit we
as cisgender people do a really bad job
of standing up for people who aren't
cisgender I call out the fact that
cisgender queer people are treated
differently than non-cisgender queer
people and until we do better we don't
deserve to have the letters be together
much better grounds so I mean I I kind
of I agree with what you're saying but I
think in general this conversation can
become very hostile because it seems
like you know I I'm like oh I don't want
you to be a part like I don't want you
to be my friend I don't want to be with
you be next to you be seen with you and
that's not the case one is an identity
and one is a sexuality and and that's
just the simple diff difference between
the two eventually as both groups are
fighting for their own personal interest
those are going to not work cohesively
so one is going to be quieter and one is
going to get taken advantage of et
cetera and it's not that we can't
support the TQ plus right I just think
that they're two vastly different things
I think that you you oversimplify
identity versus sexuality though because
there are tons of men who identify as
straight who have on occasion with
regularity once in their life sex with
men which is why I think once with men
sure experience but I think if there is
a guy that's identifying a straight that
sometimes dabbles with men might
identifying so two things first of all
there are lots of gay men that we are a
lot that we can call Gay all day and all
night that occasionally have sex with
women and we don't question whether or
not they're gay but are you entitled to
titling someone else's tie that up to
you the the title is an objective fact
sleep with men and women than you are bi
what if someone that you were I don't
care about doesn't agree yeah if you
don't agree that's fine but the fact is
you sleep with men and women so you're
bi flat out can we not talk about who
we're having sex with
just for this problem because a lot of
what's in the media today is
sensationalized content about you know
targeting children some of it a lot of
it is valid and some of it is not but a
lot of times it's gay men that are doing
it and trans people are getting blamed
for it when it's really gay men in Drag
and because the letters are together
people don't know the difference and
even when I first started like coming
out the first thing that one somebody
said to me was are you going to
transition into a woman I'm like wait
what that has nothing to do with with my
sexuality there's nothing wrong with
doing that but because they're together
from an outsider's point of view
optically I think if we're if our goal
is to educate the populace on who we are
then we need to make a more clear
distinction between LGB and TQ plus no I
don't disagree I think it's just
important that if we do that we don't
erase any of the validity of the people
that we're not a part of and also when I
what I'm what I wonder about in this
context is some people are born intersex
so they have sexual organs of both
genders how do we identify under the
certain under the criteria you guys have
identified how would we label them
because they have both and they have sex
with only one gender what are they it's
such a rare case I don't think the
exception makes the rule yeah like
there's people born with 11 things human
beings we like to package things that we
can develop a palette for we like to
make things more palatable we like to
establish clear-cut rubrics for what is
and what is in a person I think that's
just the natural human technology our
brain categorizes but but I think that
you know what separates us from the Apes
is that we can give Credence to these
differences and create pockets of space
at least for a discussion if you don't
necessarily agree or whatever you know
I think it would be an incredible
disservice to the transgender Community
who gave us a lot of the beginning for
us to fight for our rights a separation
from them now that we have our rights
that's just so privilege of us like
Marshall P Johnson through that first
break at Stonewall and because of her
she didn't throw the first break when
she got there at 2 A.M first of all and
second of all Marsh P Johnson was also a
gay man so when she was fighting for
those rights she was fighting for gay
rights because she was gay I totally
agree the time that it was
we're here to defend I'm here I'm here
to defend the TQ being part of the LGB
yes there are some gay men that will
Overlook what's underneath the belt that
happens but to say that you you have to
like them that's wrong and I also have a
heart for the queue because we can't
clearly Define the cue when I was young
it was questioning now it's queer queer
was a slur once upon a time but I look
at those people who were former
homosexuals who now live a heterosexual
lifestyle they're never going to be
accepted by the straight community and
they're not going to be accepted by our
community so I've put them under the Q
umbrella those straight people who do
have sex with the same gender on
occasion they would fall under that cue
they may not fall under the beat so I
have a heart for them because they do
exist in our spheres we just can't put
them on a pedestal above any of us
because we are all in this together I
also don't think that they should be
divorced because I'm a huge disability
Advocate I have a mental health
condition it's very different from
someone who uses a wheelchair we're
still have a disability what you're
getting at is that we're a minority
they're a minority and the more that you
take apart those minorities the harder
it is for us to fight for our rights
already divided I think separating the
two is going to make them even more
divided and a lot more animosity between
queer or queer and tea with LGBT it's a
double-edged sword because in one way
it's like okay well we don't want to
divide too much because we don't want to
lose our united front against
heteronormativity or whatever but then
at the same time if we can't teach the
nuances of our various identities to a
heteronormative society then it's like
okay well aren't you gay aren't you like
it's it's all the same thing to them so
I think it's a balance between being all
a wash and then also noting that we are
uniquely made up of all these different
different experiences but I think if we
had a stronger Community like that
wouldn't be the case I'm sorry no no
you're good like if you don't like me
because who I am I know that my brother
right here my sister right there is
gonna like me and they're gonna support
me and that's all I need because all
about my personal experience and what's
in my circle you don't need to be in my
circle but because it's within my own
Circle that I'm getting all this you
know belittlement and hatred everyone
just wants to be accepted honestly like
that's the way it's looked at and can't
we all to some extent I identify
underneath the queue your traction maybe
has shifted in some way to different
types of men like things are constantly
evolving and in my opinion fluid so to
kind of force ourselves even into the
LGB is to sit within the binary that
doesn't help any of us anyways but I
think all the cue stuff is just a matter
of your person your personality right
and we have so many different labels and
you like this kind of person then you're
this sexuality when reality just goes
back to but it's not your gay straight
or buy and then your personality but our
community is not doing itself any
Services by categorizing ourselves bear
twink yeah and then and then you see it
on the on the apps on the profiles oh no
fats no fans know this no that we're
already segregating ourselves we can
still be a community while having a
better way of explaining what the
differences are between the letters
because I mean even in our conversation
today you guys are talking about a lot
of anti-lgbtq legislation and as if I
was a gay person watching I would think
oh my gosh like they're coming for my
right time they're coming from my rights
but a lot of times that legislation has
to do with the TQ plus and I'm not
saying I agree with it I'm not we don't
need to go into the legislation all I'm
saying is that the narrative that gay
men are being attacked when other
letters are not giving any Merit to the
attacks it is confusing and it's harmful
to young gay men and their success
because they're force-fed this narrative
that they can't that's totally fair but
there's been over 560 legislation bills
put into like some sort of vote right
and over 220 of those have been for
transgender that leaves what around 300
plus not just at the TQ I think that
there's a lot of nuance when it comes to
the laws that we have to talk about but
either way when you say over 500 lgbtq
plus it the the distinction between the
two gets lost
I passed one of those laws in Nebraska
that was that that protects children
under the age of 18 from receiving
gender affirming caring hormones because
I've seen that yes I am very proud
because of you because I have friends
who had their first experiences
because when I passed this legislation
that you say targets LGBT people I sat
next to a young girl who her first
experience with this type of care was a
double mastectomy at 15. she's now 19.
doesn't know if she'll be able to it's
actually very common because I promise
you're asking me a question
you passed a law that affects so many
kids from feeling like themselves
that's unfortunate and I'm ashamed
that's what it's going to take to get
you to stop so I can finish my my
thought I appreciate that all right you
know so I'm going to shut up until you
finish but I would really like to say
something when you're done sure the
person that I testified with who their
experience was uh
okay that one person was one person in
Nebraska but I know a plethora
I know a plethora of other people in
other states all over this country so
easy
can we not do this
can we let him talk you're gonna get
time to talk I don't appreciate it I
know I'm serious too but let's finish he
pissed off more than you and he's quiet
just let him you're gonna get your point
out just let him I'm good thank you just
let him talk okay let's pause you say
how many people you say it's a small
subset but for the people who it affects
it affects them for the rest of their
lives a decision that made they made as
a child will affect them for the rest of
their lives this person will never feel
their sensation on their chest they
don't know if they're going to ever be
able to have a child and they know they
will never be able to breastfeed they
will never be a woman in the regular
senses
and this is happening more and more
because we are conditioning our young
people to say hey this is okay this is
okay you can make these decisions as a
as a as a senior in this community I
have to say wait a second you guys are
kids wait till you have your whole lives
let's talk about this honestly shame on
you for not going after the actual facts
I realize your anecdotal experiences
move you and I respect and appreciate
that but let's be perfectly clear the
most permanent thing a kid can go
through is puberty first of all so when
you when you deny a kid the opportunity
to pause puberty we're just talk first
of all talk about puberty with straight
kids do all the time all the time all
the time yes since the 80s kids have
been prescribed puberty blockers for a
variety of reasons and the law you
passed prevents that so you steal from
kids who would like to be able to pause
the ability to further fewer than three
percent of people who do any kind of
transition regret it and go back fewer
than 3 percent finally I want to make
this very clear now I'm not done you
were so mean to everybody else you want
to talk to you my turn
there has been
really robust standards of care laid out
by all the leading medical associations
that has been in existence for a long
time that is science based about
guidelines for these things but to be
clear the guidelines are very specific
about this is supposed to be the parents
decision with their kid with their
medical provider what you did was Rob
all those families of choices your
opinion because you believe you know
better than science you know better than
parents you know better than people who
even do know themselves you're going to
prevent them from having options because
you personally have a problem with
something that a couple of people and
some other people you're aware of news
none of them are statistically
significant you maybe you've got dozens
of people you know of hundreds that's a
teeny tiny little sliver you will never
know or know of all of these people and
yet you've decided for them and shame on
you for it I think we all can agree
though that
even though he's past his legislation
legislation over 18 you don't care what
they do I don't care what they do you
know you're just more so protecting
those the kids he's protected that are
going to have his law is more so
protecting those kids that are just
tomboys Tom girls that are just they're
being forced for this idea like oh I'm
gay maybe I'm a girl and then like
they're just like pink they like are
more feminine and it's like oh actually
transition and I think it's that simple
and I just hate it this is such an
absolutist discussion on both sides
because it's like you guys are like no
there's nothing no don't I'm nothing
absolutely I'm not being absolutely okay
but I just don't work in my mouth okay
I'm disappointed that someone can you
let me talk about can you pass a law
that harms children
we got it so harmed already all I'm
saying is that your guys are not making
space for the people who have gone
through this process and regret it I
personally know someone in the same
situation that you were in and I'm not
sitting here arguing for either side
because I think this is a very nuanced
discussion it used to be a two-year
process now it's six months those things
are changing because the capital and the
motive behind it is now which I'm sure
that you guys on this side are against
capitalistic you know health care that's
pushing it and those guidelines yes yes
1.6 million per child that gets on it
that's throughout their lifetime that's
how much that there are so many other
things that kids get that make people
more money I understand that but you're
not leaving any room for nuance and this
is this discussion actually I would
argue that you guys aren't leaving them
for nuance because your decide you make
a decision I never made it I never said
a statement okay I apologize and for
those of you that I have been mean to I
didn't I'm sorry I love and respect all
of you as people I don't think it's me
nuances is valuable and that's why we
leave it up to the parents and the
medical professionals and the
individuals who are making these these
decisions there are people who get hair
plugs and regret it there are people who
get nose jobs and regret it there is no
such thing
kids can get nose jobs
that of course kids are getting this all
the time oh he's done she's waiting on
us sorry I think it sounds like we're
not really going to find a middle ground
between some of you we won't have to hug
but can I sort of can I actually sort of
like wrap it up into a middle ground
moment yeah I think this is exactly
going back to the point of why these
there is a separation because it's a
very lived different experience than
just being a cisgendered gay man that
was the whole point of the prompt this
is everyone's opinion no matter like how
frustrating it can be going and
attacking people like it was just a lot
um and if that was me like I would be so
mad and I would just go off so you know
I commend you for really like holding
your company and I just want to
apologize because that's absolutely
right and I broke my own rule in being
fired up in the things I said to you and
I'm sorry that's not a problem you
deserve to be treated and I ultimately
do side with my liberal Brothers
um that I don't agree with the
legislation but I it's not malicious I
see where you're coming from and I that
exists and people that live here they do
they have that but I I do disagree with
legislation but I don't necessarily have
to personally attack you
drag shows are too sexual for minors
I think it's important to not put a
blanket statement over everything
um because I know already when they step
forward that we're going to get the
Missed Out Fire example and then it's
going to be like oh well why is that
okay for kids and drag it's not I love a
good drag show I frequent them all the
time
most of them are not appropriate for
children most of them not all but most
of them there are instances that are
circulating on social media that
represent a small minority of drag shows
where kids are present and then it's
over sexualized people pleasuring
themselves wearing outfits that are
representative of genitalia for that
reason I would say that drag typically
is not appropriate for children do I
think it needs to be legislated no
because I don't trust the government to
legislate it responsibly but I do trust
parents to use their better judgment and
know that when something is typically
sexual it most likely will be so just
don't take your kids there yeah I
disagree with them there were folks
trying to band drag you can't do that we
have the First Amendment free expression
I think drag should be able to be
celebrated and just kind of address
however you want I think it is good I
think it's great but then sometimes
there are instances where it's none like
we have to talk about that rather than
being fan drag or no it's completely
safe I think we need to have that middle
ground conversation on what that means
as a child who wore my sister's clothes
I wore my mom's makeup I put on their
heels I did all the things I just
explored my you know who I was feeling
comfortable expressing yourself and and
being around Jack could be like for a
kid like me if I saw that it was okay to
dress up and and nobody was like shaming
me maybe that could be helpful but that
doesn't change the fact that the
majority of drag shows that we see today
are sexualized well we have to even
start with drag as where its origin
comes from here it happens mostly in
bars that's where these Queens are
getting their training I myself and my
time have helped a drag queen organize a
show that was family friendly and I used
the quotations because she actually took
it out of a bar she's like we can't make
something family friendly and still
produce it in a place where they serve
alcohol so she actually ended up renting
a theater asking people to pay for
tickets and she put on a produced show
where they came in from backstage and
they would come on on stage like you
would expect to see a Broadway show and
she made sure that she told anybody that
was going to come in and perform you
don't grab your breasts you don't grab
your crotch you don't shake you don't do
we have to make sure that it has to be
available and consumable for the general
public because we don't know who's going
to be walking through our doors and we
have a responsibility and a duty to make
sure that we don't confuse children we
don't upset people and if we want this
show to be a success we have to make it
palatable for as many people as possible
okay
okay well it's right here
we don't say the same thing about pop
stars it's literally the same thing you
know and I think that it's hyper myopic
zoned in because we are queer it's an
easy way to go after us I don't think
most people that don't like drag shows
are angry about drag shows actually care
about drag shows or whatever have ever
even been to one you know I think when
you go you said majority I've not been
to all the drag shows I can't speak for
the majority but I've been to my fair
share in New York and la like places
where the Queens turn out they put on a
show it is not about being sexual it's
about being smart funny witty they make
their costumes they do their makeup it
is Art is entertaining
I don't think they get enough respect
for what they do and inside that drag is
kind of being painted that way for
everyone when there are a lot of people
that are doing beautiful work but what
do you think when it does I think people
across the line like being inherently
afraid of drag as an art form then go to
the one thing that they can which is
like oh the sexualization of the minor
like but I I which which I think you
know such a dog whistle if you're not
taking out all the naked statues that
are like all over Italy and like in the
Catholic Church like you know I mean
like naked babies if you're gonna like
say well none of none of the like
sexually sexualization of children and
none of the inappropriateness then you
have to go after it all of it and I will
and I will get with you guys on that
point where it is hyper focused on the
drag queens when it is a bigger
conversation of what is acceptable not
acceptable for children especially pop
stars when I've been to Beyonce's tour
four times this year so far
you need to go while I'm there I love
the experience I love the show but I'm
also fighting in my head being like a
super big fan but I'm like this is
really inappropriate for children but no
one's talking about that because it's
Beyonce because it's Beyonce there's so
much footage out there of adult women
with their minor daughters going to a
Justin Bieber concert and being out of
their minds about him being in any way
sexual they respond when he does a
sexual thing this is a norm it's just
that in this case it's about queer
people and Norms don't get to apply to
us right and I think that just art in
general has the potential to you know
blur the lines of what's socially
acceptable and what isn't that's what
makes it art so it's important to
remember that all forms of Art and I
speak on this on my platforms too I'm
not when I have kids they're not going
to Hooters I'm sorry I'm not taking them
there I'm also not taking them to a drag
show and I'm not going to take them to a
Sam Smith concert either so and that's
not because that art is bad it's because
I'm not comfortable with my kids being
there but if the government for you yes
you said that you feel like you maybe
could have experienced something that
was good for you by seeing drag when you
were little right so I mean I just said
you wouldn't take your kids because the
majority of drag shows that I've seen I
wouldn't find appropriate I'm not going
to run the risk I'm not saying that
there isn't a drag show that would be
good for a child I never said that I'm
saying that from my experience going to
drag shows I'm not going to run the risk
of taking my kid and putting them in an
environment that I don't deem do you
want kids I mean yes we have a
responsibility to police our own
Community if a drag queen comes out of
the out from backstage into a bar and
someone has their child that drag queen
should be like stop whose Child is This
why is this child in this bar under 21
excuse me they're going to lose their
alcohol license especially in California
although I do think that they're a
wonderful draft shows that are amazing
for adults Also may not be appropriate
for children but it's not inherently the
art form that determines I agree I mean
the vast majority of drag shows happen
in places that are 21 and up so it's not
as if there's a rash of kids being taken
into bars but that I think it's really
important to note that the argument
about whether or not a certain art form
is inappropriately sexual or not is a
tale as old as time I think drag is
being targeted because it pings that
part of people who aren't sure what's
okay adults take their young kids to
Hooters all the time adults show their
kids R-rated movies all the time but
those are their personal choices and
here's the thing it is not unknown
what's developmentally appropriate the
American Psychological Association the
American Associated Pediatrics there's
tons of well-researched guidance on this
this is not an open question there's no
need for these laws but also it's not
accurate to say that most of them are
sexualized because how in the world
would you be able to empirically prove
that totally
I would date a trans man
every trans person has their own
experience of what trans is if that
trans man still had
downstairs then sure because that's the
reason I'm gay I'm a gay man because I'm
a male with uh male body parts that
likes male body parts I have a question
for you yeah
would that change let's say if you met
someone and you were attracted them
based off of what they looked like in
clothes and then you found out that
their genitalia didn't match what you
had expected or assumed would you still
not be interested in them it would hurt
because I would be interested in them
that's happened before I can't be
interested in a person but at the end of
the day I'm gay
so if I go downstairs and there's
nothing there or there is a female body
part I can't perform so then you
wouldn't date a trans man would you
the trans man is woman transitioning to
man
yeah so it's like you you wouldn't
because if they didn't trans woman trans
man which is woman transition to man
that's right no okay you can turn around
okay yeah no okay so reset
um I think for myself I've never uh had
the opportunity I would say the
privilege personally it is one of those
things where like what I look for in a
partner is really what they bring to the
table in terms of like intellectual
conversation and just the way they make
me feel it doesn't really matter what
you have going on if we have good
chemistry up here like that's not going
to be a problem at all and it shouldn't
be a problem and no one should really be
conformed or confined to what they have
in their pants I was dating someone and
they were transitioned they didn't tell
me we're like two months in and we
actually decide to actually do something
I don't think that's fair for me though
because you're not giving me the
opportunity if I still want to continue
because that's important so that's why I
don't blame anyone or have any I'm on a
messy if someone doesn't want to date a
trans person because they still have
their preference and if they are gay
it's not just gender that's important
it's also their sex that's important too
and we don't want to disregard sex as
well and what their sexual identity is
because that is important to someone
else I also think you know just based on
the idea that you're talking about with
sex there's so much more to sex than
just penetration or sucking on something
specific I think that there's a lot of
different ways to enjoy sex and being
sexual with your partner I also think
you know for us to sit here and think
about the trans experience is completely
unfair because we don't go through it
and so for someone who is trans to think
about disclosure is safety for me
personally I think that love is such a
special thing and to be able to find it
in any capacity would be a gift and I
think to close yourself off from
possibly meeting someone who you are
physically attracted to because of what
just is in their pants is really doing
yourself a disservice
can we go around and say what we love
about each other
um I think I think we all have a
sexuality for a reason that's not
discounting the lives of trans people
like I think they have the rights they
should be alive like that's totally fine
respect to them but I think we're uh
at least some of us here are gay for a
reason our sexuality is reduced to
what's between the pants that's
literally
the only reason I'm a gay man we're
talking about like what's in someone's
pants yeah would you date a trans woman
who still had her penis I'd be open to
it
so would that make you still gay though
if she presents as a woman yes
it would make me
buy with an exception well your
definition of gay is defined by being
attracted to be like I want that would
be a very very feminine man when it
comes to men obviously there's what's in
your pants but them transitioning to a
man they're still identified as a man
and they still present that masculinity
that most men if you want to be honest
most CIS men can't produce right yeah so
if me wanting to date a train me wanting
to date are open to dating a trans man
does that not make me gay I would say
that you're bi with an attraction to
masculinity or pansexual these
conversations are so tough for me
because it's like I truly believe that
you love who you love and it doesn't
care it doesn't matter and we categorize
things because that's natural for the
brain but there are nuances and there
are exceptions honey I'm as gay as the
Sun is hot but I like you know what I
like it I'm sorry somebody else's
sexuality totally by saying oh you're
bigoted for not wanting to do this
because that and it kind of goes back to
our other discussion where the TQ and
then the LGB sometimes those issues can
can intermingle and then cause other
people to feel invalidated just because
I don't necessarily want to date
somebody with a vagina when this
conversation interesting because to me I
don't see the point in it because like
we can argue that someone who is a gay
man will did a trans man it's like who
cares that's up to them I know that we
have definitely thank you right I think
it just sucks though that gay men are
being called transphobic for not wanting
data trans man I can all agree that's
wrong that's yeah I think that's
transphobic at all that's not your
preference or if that's not who you like
then that's fine can't nobody get upset
at you
um but I think it is one of those things
where like you know sometimes it it is
not what you say about how you say it
that's fair I've gone to like eight
clubs and trans people have been there
and you know we're all supposed to be
like under one umbrella we're all
supposed especially in a gay club like
you would think like you know
everybody's just kind of hyping people
up but it's not the case where it's like
you know you step in there pumps on you
know wearing a skirt and you have like
six CIS gay men eyeing you down or
treating you differently all because
you're transgender so it's not even a
situation of oh I don't like you because
that's not my type but it's the way you
go about it that's fair I only didn't
step up because I've never faced this
however
of all the kinds of men that I'm into
and I kind of have into a wide variety
of men my assumption is I don't think
I'll be sexually satisfied if my partner
doesn't have a penis that's it that's it
and that's and that's good for you for
you that's fine for me for me yeah I
have other plans
lgbtq topics should be taught in school
in the middle
I think age appropriate for sure yeah
exactly it's nuanced it's age and grade
it that depends on that but I mean
there's definitely times growing up when
I was in the closet in middle school I'm
like okay we're taught men and women
they get together and then they have a
baby whatever especially ninth 10th
grade but like for gay people so I mean
it just that doesn't exist we don't like
women so like what is my experience I'm
not reading it in the book I'm not
singing anywhere I'm having to run to
the dark corners of the internet I'm
having to experience all these things
that they shouldn't just be going
through we should be teaching something
at least but and it goes back over a
sexualization thing it's like when
people say are iffy about gay topics
being brought up in school it's like oh
the sex but it's like no like right like
why can't we learn about wholesome
relationships hold them or like you know
and just having good credit like you
know making good financial decisions
people like just things that are so much
bigger well yeah and that's why I
originally was hesitant to step forward
because there is a fine line people are
talking about the don't say gay bill or
their parental rights and education bill
in Florida which was up to grade three
it's it's important for kids to know
that two people they change that though
yes
either way either way well when it was
originally up to grade three that's when
I would say I agreed with it right
because I don't think that it is a the
government's place to teach my future
child about sexuality now hear me out
this is why it's a gray area when
teachers open the discussion to young
children about sexuality and inherent
sexual attraction it puts them in a
position where they could step on the
toes of parents and that's what I don't
agree with I totally understand where
you're going with sexuality I totally
understand uh what YouTube said
age-appropriate I think when you're
talking about sexuality that's like sex
that's in terms of like sexual education
sex ed that's literally what they teach
in school so that those types of talk
either which is the point I was going to
make okay I don't think I'm a
conservative who favors small government
I don't think it's the government's
place to teach anyone's kids about sex
and I know there are kids that may need
to learn about it because their parents
aren't good parents but I don't think
that exception makes the world that's
good for you I'm sorry that's good for
you but in just into it's taught with
the way the world is moving now and the
way that the community is just so open
and so expressive and the child is going
to see regardless so like he was saying
instead of going to you know the dark
web or you know just looking stuff up on
your own and having no guidance if
you're going to teach somebody or if
somebody's going to learn it you rather
them learn the correct way I can totally
totally get down with that too you want
to have parental rights in what you're
they're saying my whole point is that it
has to be all or nothing we can't keep
straight sexuality yeah I agree
hey girl always always me
I'm kidding I'm kind of I was listening
in and Clarkson kind of made the point
that the government really shouldn't be
in the business of teaching your
children about your sexuality no one
taught us how to be gay who taught you
how to be gay anybody was it the
internet okay um it would have yeah my
uncle actually I didn't know he was gay
so it was a family member yeah I didn't
know but for me as a as a gay man who
grew up with parents who were very very
prudish they had no idea they didn't
want to have a conversation I am those
that example that should have been
taught at school but I learned I figured
it out on my own just like many of us
ultimately do I know as an individual it
would have helped me if someone in my
own family an uncle a parent for me I
think it's a government's job to start
educating these parents because the
parents need to have these sensitive
conversations with their children the
best metric for a child's success is the
parental involvement and what we're
doing right now we're teaching the
children about sexuality and completely
not involving the parent we are leading
them down a road for psychological
issues because they've got no support
system at home we're creating a school
system that's supportive and a home
system that they think is unsupportive
we live in 2023 most of the people are
very accepting parents are understanding
but parents have to know what's going on
in their children's lives so that they
can be prepared and I think it's the
school's responsibility to prepare those
parents not to have children have these
conversations with parents because
children do not teach their their
parents how do you get parents involved
when they don't support it though like I
have a lot of really good friends who
are Educators and they want the parents
involved but a lot of their parents are
coming to school already queerphobic
right see and that's where that's the
challenge that's the challenge for the
schools that it's not the school's job
to overstep that unsupportive parent and
then shelter that child because now that
child has created a two two World System
where I feel safe here but I don't feel
safe at home and then the state comes
and takes the children which is
happening how do you feel about waivers
like how do you feel about school saying
oh we're going to teach your kid this
and the kid comes home with the way
we're like if they sign it then you're
okay with the school of teaching it but
the parent doesn't sign it then they go
another room yeah absolutely something
like that I would completely agree with
that yeah I just keep thinking about as
you say that is I have a friend who
um had a great life at home until his
parents found out he was gay and then
they shut him out shot him out they
kicked him out of the house they still
haven't spoken to me since late 20s now
and he was unable to get in-state
tuition in college because they would
not help him fill out the FAFSA which
requires him to have their tax
information and so would it be great to
live in a world where a it's possible to
reach all parents and educate them and
change them from being bigoted great
would it be great to be in a place where
that is doable awesome but you know I
was groomed by a teacher
um and it was only possible
because it was not okay for teachers to
talk about being gay except the one
teacher who went out of his way to make
his room a safe space and because he was
the only teacher and happened also
separately from being open to be a
pedophile he was able to groom myself
and others and so unless and until
kids feel like they can be completely
safe wherever they are and knowing that
changing parents is kind of an
impossible lift to be frank
um not making it mandatory to create
safe spaces for lgbtq kids in schools is
begging for disappointment begging for
failure and to your point about learning
about being gay
the things the ways I ended up being gay
especially from the internet I'm almost
40. there's baggage from that that I
still carry with me 100 and so if I had
been comprehensively educated when I was
a kid in school
I would be my life would be meaningfully
different today I think for me the
easiest thing to look at is like where
you have sex education teen pregnancy
goes down right education is power I
think it would be something similar for
queer people like if we had information
about who we can be and how we can exist
in all these different ways it would
Empower kids in a way that they should
be in power there wouldn't be Billboards
for prep everywhere
monogamous relationships are difficult
to find in the gay community
I'm a step forward on this one
I think it's difficult in today's agent
and like just in general like to find a
monogamous relationship you know I
started with experience at an earlier
age so I'm 22 now I lost my virginity at
16. me being 22 I know from all the
experience with different partners and
just having you know I guess my fun I am
looking for something with substance you
know I'm at the age Gap where a lot of
you know people around my age they want
to have their fun you know they probably
just lost their Virginia 18 19 some
people are losing their virginity now
which is fine you know what I mean so
they want to experience life or hook up
culture and then there are some people
who that's just what they want to do for
the rest of their life they don't want
to be tied down so it makes it very
difficult because a lot of times even
meeting someone it's one of those things
where they want their cake and eat it
too like you know I think there's
something to be said about a lot of gay
men and again this is straight people do
this too but we're just talking about
gay people that say they want monogamy
but they don't actually want it they
just want it for the person they're with
and there's that's a little shade to my
ex but anyways
um no but I think it I think it has more
to do with the fact that we are very
focused on our pleasure a lot in our
community and we haven't really learned
not necessarily to repress it because
you shouldn't repress sexual desire but
we haven't really learned how to control
it in situations that are particularly
hard to do like if you're around
somebody that you're extremely sexually
attracted to if you haven't you know
taken the time to examine yourself and
make sure your actions correlate with
the way you want to live then you're
going to cheat or you're going to need
an open relationship because you you
just have no capability of doing
anything otherwise I think we're still
healing from the generational trauma
that came from the AIDS epidemic you
know I think a lot of people are still
trying to figure out how to heal from
that and I do think that we have a big
problem with substance abuse sex
addiction and I think that that needs to
be addressed as a community and I think
as we start to look at like why we are
leaning into these things that are less
productive for us on our like regular
lives we can start to realize maybe like
this is part of that I think whether
it's you know monogamous or
non-monogamous it's a couple's choice to
figure out what works best for them I
think we've become very married to the
idea of marriage and General where
people are willing to get divorced and
remarried and divorced remarried where
it's like you're not really married to
the person you're married to the
monogamy that comes with that marriage
I hear a lot of gays complain about this
but then they're looking on grinder for
a long-term relationship
um I don't know how you expect to do
that and who I have talked to they're
looking in the wrong places it seems
like it seems like there's a need to
like have a monogamous relationship and
I think that's good because I have one
but like since divorce rates are so high
I wonder if it would be best if people
did share each other not like all the
time but it's like you date someone
maybe you try science with someone else
I'm not saying that's the right way I
just don't know because someone
obviously some don't I don't know I
think love involves sacrifice and I
think sacrificing your desire for
somebody else for the person you're with
is ultimately what makes your love grow
deeper it's very hard for me to see an
open relationship and think you're not
willing to just commit to one person and
and just not
be with somebody else but is that a
Christian idea is that a heteronormative
idea
because as a student of science the most
stable bond is a pair bond period sure
but a pair bond for how long it can be
forever in my pair bond I'm expecting it
to be is there Nuance in that though
because even as straight couples there's
like I mean you get in the 40s and 50s
there's swingers oh absolutely you know
we did not arrive at monogamy through
Evolution It's a combination of some
things and there are benefits to pairing
but there are plenty of mammals in the
wild that don't do lifelong pairing one
of the leading drivers of uh divorce is
cheating and it seems to me taking that
off the table is a great way to prevent
that one Pitfall some of the happiest
same-sex couples I know are in open
relationships and they make all kinds of
other sacrifices for each other making
space for each other in other ways I
think we might be best served by
surrendering that one of these is right
and one of these is wrong because we put
peop each other and ourselves in a
position of an expectation of I should
want this or I should want that I should
be this I should be that and if that's
inconsistent with what best serves us
that's a recipe for a failed
relationship regardless of whether or
not it's supposed to be open or closed
you know I just want to say that I
um really respect and appreciate all of
you and I I even those of you that I
disagree with vehemently I see a lot of
humanity in and and I also want to say
um if I said or did anything that was
offensive to anyone girl I just want you
to know I really do respect the out
of you guys yeah you guys are all
amazing I'm happy to see our message you
know even if we don't always agree the
best part is that we each get to say
what we want to say and that's going to
help move our community forward that's
really what this is all about I
definitely respect all humans I just
feel like you have a lot of energy and
passion that I wish would be used
to help move the needle for all of our
community in a better way I just get
nervous that sometimes in these red
spaces they will use people like you to
push their agenda to harm one group of
people and then that will grow and grow
and grow I think they do that on both
sides yeah everybody but who is to say
that I'm not using that you guys
remember okay can we have that sound
right
[Music]
oh my gosh
foreign